[Music]
morning everybody it is seven o'clock
here in the uk you are very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news this morning petrol stations in
some parts of the country
have run out of fuel this morning after
a weekend which saw panic buying and
scuffles on four courts we'll have the
latest on this developing story as the
government considers calling in the army
to help and appeals to retired lorry
drivers to save the day we'll talk to
the petrol retailers association plus
the mayor of london city khan also this
morning we'll talk to the shadow
chancellor rachel reeves as a row over
the deputy labour leader angela rayner's
comments calling conservatives scum
overshadows the party conference
and
are you planning a last-minute getaway
but not quite sure what the new rules
are or indeed where to go we'll be
answering all of your holiday questions
live with travel experts claire evan and
simon colder 9 45 so do send us your
questions who wouldn't want to be doing
that right now monday 27th of september
pumped up as petrol runs out at some
garages around the country causing anger
and long queues the government considers
calling in the army
i do uber so it's quite difficult for me
you know i need i need i need petrol and
obviously there's not
a lot around so you know if i don't get
pets i don't get no food
i'm live at a petrol station in west
london which is expecting a delivery
this morning after a weekend of panic
buying led to fights on forecourts and
large queues at pumps
i'm live at the labour party conference
in brighton as the party tries to move
on from its infighting meanwhile
government ministers are embroiled in
more talks to try and fix the fuel
crisis
and i'm live in berlin as the results of
the german election come in anger
merkel's party have been overtaken uh by
the left of center spd but it's not
certain that their man olaf schultz will
be the next chancellor
i'm live in la palma as some evacuated
residents are able to go home but with a
warning the volcano could continue
erupting for weeks
fastlane to jail our environmental
campaign has prepared to break an
injunction to keep protesting on the m25
like these scenes last week we'll talk
to insulate britain
[Music]
morning if you're driving to work this
morning and need fuel
will you be able to fill up the tank
petrol stations in some parts of the
country have basically run dry the
government now says it's considering
calling in the army to help after a
weekend of panic buying a shortage of
lorry drivers has led to fuel supply
issues for garages with the government
appealing for retired drivers to come
back and save the day emergency measures
were triggered last night by the
business secretary quasi quatern who
chose to suspend competition laws for
the fuel industry to allow companies to
work together to target filling stations
running low milena viselivic reports
a rush to fill up the tank for the
working week
days into this crisis there's no sign of
let up and those skewing say they have
no other choice
i need it for work and we have a very
important week this week and it is it's
imperative that i do have fuel for for
the for the for for the juries that i
have to take i'm a carer for my mom and
everything as well so it's quite
important for me to be able to get to
and from places so yeah it's been
difficult i'm a pco driver i do i do
uber so it's quite difficult for me you
know i need i need i need petrol and
obviously there's not
a lot around so you know if i don't get
pets you i don't get no food that's what
i look at
this station usually serves cab drivers
but it's run dry and it's starting to
affect their livelihood
imagine you get a good job going to
bristol or reading how are you going to
manage if our people like they are
turning down the jobs the big jobs like
bristle like munchie said we can't you
can't do it because everybody knows that
you can go but how there's no guarantee
you're gonna get fuel coming back to
london
there are calls to prioritize key
workers like home carers many of whom
say they can't get to their vulnerable
patients
some of them were
very distressed by the fact they
couldn't get fuel because they were
trying to get to
people that they're supporting on end of
life care for example who had time
critical pain medic medication to give
and
once they get behind on their rotors
it's very very difficult then to catch
up the government has suspended
competition laws so companies can work
together to restock petrol stations but
that won't solve the severe shortage of
hgv drivers which is the cause of the
problem the average age of a lorry
driver is 55 and 2000 of them leave the
industry each week according to the road
haulage association and only a thousand
new recruits replace them
poor quality of life on the road is
partly to blame insiders say
this is a cocktail of problems as to why
people don't want to do it anymore but
the conditions out on the road for
safety
is one thing for parking safely and
for being able to find facilities for
themselves where they can wash their
hands go to the bathroom have a shower
we need to address that
until a chronic shortage of drivers is
tackled
more supply chain crunches could lie
ahead
milano is
joining us now is the head of the uk
petrol retailers association brian
madison hello to brian thanks for
joining us what sort of mess are we in
i think there is some good news okay
that in northern ireland there's been no
panic buying fuel supplies are normal
and
no issues to report and the same in
parts of rural scotland and rural wales
so it looks as though the panic buying
has really been uh exacerbated in the
main urban sense particularly in england
where some of our members large groups
with a portfolio of sites
report 50 percent are dry as of
yesterday some even report as many as 90
dry yesterday so you can see that it is
quite acute we represent the independent
dealers with the major fuel brands bp
shell jet and so on uh we don't
represent uh the
supermarkets nor the old company site
but certainly for our members uh monday
morning is going to start be dry for
them
whose fault is it
the whistleblower who leaked a
confidential bp report to the cabinet
meeting on the 16th of september which
was picked up by a main broadcaster and
broadcast last wednesday
and immediately that happened
there was panic buying from thursday
friday saturday and yes some of the
volumes i mean one of our members
who's got a very large site he reported
500
more volume sales last saturday than the
previous
so people have not been going and buying
their normal 20 pounds 20 liters
to get them through the week they've
actually been topping up every time and
of course with 36 million vehicles on
the road the capacity in their tanks is
way more than we have underground on the
floor
shouldn't the public know if there's
going to be a problem though is is it
reasonable to criticize the
whistleblower
yes i think so because it was being uh
entirely well contained at that point by
industry
and by government who were moving
towards uh some solution so
we really just didn't need this um
whistle uh to set off panic buying and
caused mayhem that we now have i think
it was completely
irresponsible action
so what's the solution now what do we do
given we are where we are what happens
next
there are no big levers k depaul but the
series of small levers which industry
and government now looking towards which
includes as your program has mentioned
the possibility of military drivers
however that is not quite as easy if you
think because the hgv tanker drivers are
a highly trained specialized breed
they've got 42 000 liters of highly
inflammable liquid they're moving around
the country from terminal to full blood
and they do the loading from the gantry
into their tanker and they do the
discharge when they get to the fall
and they need to be certain that they're
putting the right fuel into the right
pot in the full board because as we know
petrol and diesel diesel petrol may
cause havoc with your engine within a
few hundred yards of leaving the
forklift so
we can't immediately take the military
drivers uh without first sorting out the
loading of the country and be filling up
the
there are possibilities of bringing back
uh
drivers from the continent
but there are hgv shortages right across
the continent germany poland italy
france they've all got problems so
quite how many we can attract back just
for three months and that's all the
government are allowing in their
temporary exemption pieces from the
first of october to the end of the year
how many will come back in that time
scale and how many will immediately be
efficient we're not quite certain one of
the issues though is with the dvla the
driver and vehicle licensing agency
it said that they are sitting on 40 000
applications by uk citizens for an hdv
driver um license and they have had
strikes this year down in swansea
they have had working from home but
whatever is going on it's completely
unacceptable performance and this is the
responsibility of grand shepherd's
department on transport and i just
wonder whether he's actually ever been
to swansea to try and sort out the mess
that we've got
all of this sounds like it's going to be
quite a long and laborious process how
long before we won't have to queue for
fuel anymore
well hopefully a lot of cars have now
got a lot of fuel in and instead of
having half a tank they've got a full
tank so
we are watching and waiting uh from
probably about wednesday onwards to see
whether there is a dissipation in the
volume of traffic coming into forklift
trying to fill up
but of course this thing is self
prophesying if you need fuel for work to
take kids to school to go and visit
granny and her care home um fuel
absolutely is essential around the uk
and what we've seen strangely
is that the market for second-hand cars
has been going up every month normally
it goes down of course but every month
it's been going up because people are
afraid of using public transport so
they're buying themselves a little
banger for four or five thousand pounds
and using that to get to work and do
their daily routines and so there's
possibly a bit more traffic on the road
than we've had here too
um so but just to answer my question in
a nutshell um brian you think that we
should be back to normal
by the end of this week
i'm keeping my fingers crossed that it
will be less of a problem by the end of
this
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us mr madison appreciate you
taking the time ahead of uk's petrol
retailers association thank you
well um yeah bit of a crisis going on
isn't that we requested to speak to a
minister about the crisis this morning
but they've told us that they won't be
putting any ministers forward for
morning interviews during labour party
conference
aisha zaid is at a petrol station in
west london for us this morning which
has run out of fuel but is expecting a
delivery imminently and what will the
politicians do next we're waiting to
hear if there's a cabinet this morning
tomorrow cohen is in brighton at the
labour party conference ash to you first
of all it looks as though they've got
some fuel again have they behind you
yeah that's right the delivery has
arrived in the last few moments and you
can see people starting to fill up now a
massive queue has built here in the past
hour uh cars queuing all the way down
blocking parts of the a4 as well
now they initially ran out of fuel here
last night around 10 p.m but that didn't
stop cars from
coming overnight uh passing through
trying their luck to see if they were
able to fill up it has definitely felt
busier since five o'clock and six
o'clock this morning cues were building
even when there were no when there was
no fuel here and some of these cars have
been waiting several hours now speaking
to some of the drivers this morning it's
been a mix of reasons as to why they're
here some people desperate to fill up
before they head to work and others
panic buying but it's important to note
that the problem isn't with a shortage
of fuel it's a problem with getting the
fuel to the foreports due to a lack of
hgv drivers and over the weekend we know
the government held emergency talks
about the issue
so and
so at the moment there is still massive
massive problems on the forehouse
okay thanks tomorrow as i said also um
in brighton that will be a topic of
conversation tomorrow in brighton they
have other issues to deal with as well
good morning
good morning k yes labour have so far
said what they would do is give visas
200 000 foreign lorry drivers to come in
and try and sort this out the moment the
government are considering still whether
they bring in members of the armed
forces to drive petrol tankers so far
all these entreaties to everybody to not
panic by petrol have still led to big
queues at four courts and a number of
petrol stations actually closed
what has developed over the last 24
hours or so the business secretary quasi
quatern has met has spoken to the big
fuel companies and decided to suspend
competition law what this means is that
the different companies that supply
petrol will be able to share information
with each other about where the
bottlenecks are and actually deliver to
each other's forecourt so that should
help a bit at the margins is what i'm
told by senior people in government but
certainly talks between ministers it
won't be a full cabinet meeting but
talks between ministers will be
continuing today
uh and as far as labor is um concern
we're going to be speaking to rachel
reeves a little bit
later on but they're embroiled in a bit
of a row aren't they
that's right kay a bit bit of infighting
dominating proceedings over the weekend
as kierstama tried to get through some
big changes to the rules about how
labour elected future leaders they could
broadly say that these are intended to
prevent a left-wing jeremy corbyn style
leader coming in in future he did
actually get those through last night
looked a bit dicey at times but he'll be
very relieved by that and today they're
trying to get the focus back onto policy
with rachel reeves who wants to be the
next chancellor of the exchequer saying
if labour were elected they would scrap
business rates the taxes paid by high
street shops which they say put them at
an unfair disadvantage to the likes of
amazon but where do they find that 30
billion pounds
okay thank you
i'll be speaking to rachel uh reeve
later on in the program now word about a
new program starting on sky news and sky
showcase this evening trevor phillips
can tell us more
their headlines from another generation
food and fuel shortages rising taxes
warnings of a winter of discontent
but this is the uk today
every monday we'll be discussing the
topic dominating the news and we'll be
putting you in charge on the great
debate
this week is britain running on empty
and you can watch the great debate
tonight nine o'clock on sky showcase and
here of course on sky news
still to come on the program before you
half past seven gonna be speaking to the
boxer amir khan about claims that he was
removed from a flight in the u.s after a
reported row over face coverings
twenty two eight i'm going to be joined
by insulate britain to discuss the
injunction which bans them from blocking
the m25 motorway what are they going to
do about that
and then at quarters away we'll head
down to brighton as i said to speak to
the mayor of london sadiq khan as the
labour party enters the third day of its
annual conference
the preliminary results in the german
elections are in with the social
democrats taking a narrow lead um those
early results suggesting the center left
spd will win the largest share of the
vote with around 26 percent close behind
is the cdu with 24
the greens are next with 14
while the pro-business free democratic
party are on 11. the two parties are
expected to be key to forming any
coalition finally the far-right afd
party are projected to win 10 of the
vote
so as it stands the spd has the largest
share of the vote
sounds pretty complicated doesn't it our
editor at large adam bolton in berlin
he'll clear it all up for us right now
hi adam a very good morning a lot of
acronyms there what does it all mean
well what it really means k is first of
all we don't need to keep talking about
preliminary results we know the pattern
of the night and the pattern of the
night is is that the equivalent of the
labour party the spd uh have taken the
largest share of the votes
their vote is up fairly dramatically
they've overtaken angela merkel's old
party the cdu csu the center left
christian democrats center-right
christian democrats
so it's been a bad night for them and
their vote is down considerably we also
know that the greens
have done pretty well now because
germany has a proportional
representation system
it's not first past the post so the spd
won't be able to form a government they
need uh to get a majority of seats
behind them in the
german parliament behind me
that means there's going to have to be a
coalition that will involve at least
three parties to get over the 50
and just the way the maths work uh there
is a possibility that the party which
has come second angela merkel's own
party could uh assemble a majority
itself excluding the party which has
actually come first the spd it's more
likely that the spd though will manage
to form a coalition probably uh with the
liberals the fdp and with the greens
in second place but if the liberals and
the greens decided that they wanted to
go
with angela berkel's old grouping of the
cdu csu
they could technically do that but
i think we need to calm down a bit the
fact is the momentum is with the spd
we're going to hear from them later on
this morning and their leader is olaf
schultz now he is 63
and he's well known to germans i mean he
is currently serving as the finance
minister and also uh the deputy
chancellor and he
looks like the man uh assuming the
parties can agree over what's likely to
be weeks of
negotiations he looks like the man he'll
be the next chancellor
and that coalition which he's going to
have to form in order to take office uh
is likely to be
a partnership with uh and elena bairbach
she is the leader of the greens she
apologized for them not doing better and
blamed her own mistakes but she will
probably be the deputy chancellor and
then the liberals the yellow in this
traffic light coalition the fdp they're
led by a christian linda he's a good
communicator
they are initially going to talk to each
other the greens and the liberals to
decide which of the
two big parties they're going to
approach first about forming a three-way
coalition
okay adam see i told you i'd explain it
all for you thanks so much indeed adam
live in berlin thank you he's so clever
now what about this alan lancaster do
you remember him of course you do the
bass guitarist and founding member of
status quo he's died at the age of 72.
let's take a listen to one of their
famous tunes
[Music]
[Applause]
he really did rock all over the world
from germany to japan california to
copenhagen and of course an endless list
of iconic performances on home soil that
was actually nebworth in 1990 performing
in front of many tens of thousands of
fans the band's singer francis rossi has
led tributes calling his colleague an
integral part of status quo's sound and
success over the years that pub quiz
question remember of course who opened
live aid back in the 80s at wembley yep
let's take a look at the other stories
making news this morning
the internet provider talk talk is
rolling out a new scheme giving uk job
seekers free broadband the initiative
which is backed by the government has
come about as recruitment processes and
training has moved online due to the
pandemic job seekers will be offered a
six-month voucher for unlimited internet
usage
campaigners in san marino are
celebrating after the country voted to
legalize abortion overturning a hundred
and fifty year old law in the process
some 77 percent of voters approved a
referendum proposal calling for abortion
to be legal in the first 12 weeks of
pregnancy according to official results
authorities in two indian coastal states
are on high alert with evacuations and
preparations underway as a cyclone hit
the eastern seaboard the indian
meteorological department says cyclone
gulab coming in from the bay of bengal
began to make landfall late on sunday
evening with wind speeds of up to 59
miles an hour
some residents on the island of la palma
have been allowed back home to collect
their belongings after evacuating from
their homes because of an erupting
volcano airport workers have cleared the
runway of volcanic ash thankfully but
all flights to and from la palma have
remained cancelled scientists say the
eruption which is the island's first in
50 years could last for another three
months
well these were some of the latest
pictures of the devastation caused by
the volcano from yesterday churches and
homes were destroyed by the streams of
lava after a new vent opened up on the
volcano over the weekend
live pictures of the volcano right now
showing lava spewing out
into the air on la palma as i said
another visage um figure i should say
opened up over the weekend becky
cottrell joining us from la palma now
hello to you becky what's it looking
like there good morning you have to wear
a face covering don't you because of the
ash in the air
you do yeah that's the advice for
everyone here to wear these medical
grade masks to protect from the ash and
those gases the volcano this morning is
slightly calmer than it was yesterday
when we were here we know that the
pressure inside the volcano decreased
over the weekend but that doesn't mean
the eruptions are about to stop we
simply don't know when that will happen
and just in the time we've been here you
can see these kind of intermittent
explosions of lava from the top of the
volcano and we know that lava is flowing
through freely through towns you just
mentioned that church that is in a town
called todoke it's about three miles
south of the volcano over a thousand
people live there and actually last week
that church had a near-miss the lava
stream stopped just short of it seems
now it look its look has sadly run out
but there will be many people in that
town and in evacuation zones from across
the island who were eager to get back
home and see just how bad the damage is
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thank you
let's have a look at some of these uh
amazing pictures a bit of a daring
endeavor here we go cliff diving
world champion gary hunt and rhiannon
ifland added to their hall of titles
during an event along italy's adriatic
coastline over the weekend large crowds
gathered to cheer on the participants
during the season-ending finale on
sunday and they did brilliantly didn't
they
good for them
quick look at the weather
we are entering a more autumnal spell
certainly felt like it this morning
prolonged rain giving way to widespread
showers today
hello again everybody heading to work
this morning only got a quarter of a
tank we'll be speaking to a petrol
station owner in just a moment but
before that i want to share this with
you the boxer amir khan he's revealed
that he was removed from a flight in the
u.s after a reported row over face
coverings he's 34 he was traveling on an
american airlines plane along with a
colleague last week so what on earth
happened amir is joining us now from
where he's in training camp in colorado
springs thanks for staying up for us
amir we really appreciate it tell me
what happened on that plane
so um i got on the plane and um i was on
scene number one a and one b was my
friend who my colleague who was coming
to training camp with me and um as soon
as i was on the plane i was on the i was
on a phone call um the the lady came
over to the edge to a student i said to
me to go up to take to put my phone call
down
which i did i put it down didn't argue i
had my mask on everything was fine
my friend um
must have been drinking some water put
his mask down a little bit i had a sip
of water
and the lady
then came and said please you need to
put your mask up here
it must have been just a little bit
lower than
his um
just below his nose
and um so he fixed that
and then
the plane's moving now so i'm leaning on
the side of the window and if i'm trying
to fall asleep
um all on the way to colorado for my
training camp and then the plane some
reason stops
and when it stops um i i pull up the
window just to see what's happened and
um
before you know it the doors open up and
three officers walk in and and
the students tells us to please can you
leave
and can me and my friend leave
i had done nothing wrong you know i mean
my master was always up i just didn't
feel that i got treated so badly um
it was quite embarrassing standing up
in front of a full plane
and i think even they were shocked that
you know why are the police in in the
airplane and
why they're taking those two young boys
literally sat right at the front
and um
we got literally taken out and um
they just said that we were not paying
attention to instructions they've given
us they said that my bag one of their
press releases have come and they said
that the bag
my bag was oh and i wasn't listening i
was arguing with them which i never did
i didn't argue with them and
my bag was
in the uh storage area at the top of the
at the top luggage area
um
i just feel like you know i was just
treated really badly it was a week
after 9 11 and i do feel like you know
things were a little bit tense
but to be picked on
two
asian boys that sat at the front
being pulled out in front of
a full plane it was quite embarrassing
really um
afterwards i spoke to the officers and
they said same thing look it's always an
issue with american airlines and since
i've posted it because i had to post it
because i felt like
i was just treated really wrongly and
really badly and
um
i mean
just to clarify you feel that you were
asked to get off the plane because of
the color of your skin and it was a week
after 9 11.
i'm i'm not saying that but i think it
might have something to do with that um
maybe people maybe the students and and
the people the staff didn't feel
comfortable me being their side of the
front
i mean
there was no arguments there was no
shouting or anything
uh obviously i'm a very quiet guy and i
respect when they give the instructions
i respect that and when they told me to
put the phone down which is the only
incident i had when i was on the phone
they sent to me the phone call called
down and we're going to be leaving soon
and i'm gonna put it down okay i mean
this is what american airlines said um i
just want to put this to you prior to
takeoff on the 18th of september
american airlines flight 700 with
service from newark liberty
international airport to dallas fort
worth returned to the gate to deplane
two customers who reportedly refused to
comply with repeated crew member
requests to stow luggage place cell
phones in airplane mode and a dear to
federal face covering requirements our
customer relations team has reached out
to mr khan to learn more about his
experience so that's their um
understanding of what happened have you
spoken to them since
i spoke to them once when i just got to
colorado um but at that time by that
time i was already banned from
entertaining any
uh american airline flight and also i
was banned from is at one world which is
the company that
runs
american airlines and
when i spoke to the colleague he said
he's going to go into when i spoke to
the american airlines guy he said to me
that he's going to get back to me
obviously i'm not no response back from
the american airlines team but honestly
speaking i was my phone was on airplane
mode
when i was asked to put the phone down
once that was just once i did put it
down and repeatedly they said that
they were telling me to put my put my
mask up my mask was always up so i'm
sure the plane has
um cameras on on there i don't know if
they do have them on planes but really
they need to check i mean
there was people sat next to us and
there was a little bit of a shock when
the police came in to take us out i mean
we felt like criminals you know they
like like we had done something wrong
the way we were dragged out the plane
and then later on when they recognized
me
when the policeman recognized me took a
selfie with me and obviously the max was
off then as well and that was obviously
in the airport but i just feel that
you know um having two police cars
parked outside the airplane like
like with some criminals or like we are
gonna do something
i mean it just felt really uncomfortable
and
has definitely put me off i mean
i got to train and come quite late um
and you know my trainer was obviously
upset with me coming there late but it
is what it is i mean
yeah i'm just i mean when you were
talking about it amir on on twitter i
mean you did use the hashtag not all
terrorists so you did feel that it was
racially motivated did you
yeah definitely definitely i i'm going
to stand by that because obviously um
you know being 911 a week before that
and then having two asian boys sat at
the front
you know you're gonna think we're these
young boys um and and hungry asian as
well and obviously it makes it a little
bit hard but
i hope i'm wrong
um but honestly speaking i had done
nothing wrong um i got just
kicked off a plane for no reason and was
embarrassing for us
you know we've given american airlines
the right to reply via their statement
um just tell me quickly about um
training colorado springs what's going
on
it's really good i mean i've just got
here and i'm doing a couple of a couple
of weeks here um training hopefully i
should be fighting
either end of the year or early next
year i want to
have one or two more fights before i
call it a day and
being up here you know the altitude is
amazing um and literally it is hard work
i mean just to get your breath
is a lot harder and one round feels like
10 rounds
so i'm just enjoying training and with a
new culture over here as well so he's
getting i'm getting to know
what he's like and how he can teach me
and how he can improve my style so
you're saying one or two more fights and
then it's all over for you
yeah i've been in the game a very long
time
i've been in the game i've been on the
scene since i was 17 from the olympic
game from the olympic games in all fall
in in athens 2004
and i am getting on a bit a little bit
now i'm i'm touching 35
35 in december so
you're a baba um quick thought before i
let you go about aj getting beat
yeah i mean no one ever expected that
you know i mean joshua is a great
champion and you know i'm sure he's
gonna go back to the drawing board and
see where he made the mistakes and he's
gonna come back stronger i mean look
this is boxing for you you win someone
you lose some but he needs to you know
have his chin up high and you know he's
gonna get a lot of hate which comes with
the territory uh he's a huge name in
boxing and
i just hope he comes back stronger and
he gets the rematch against suzuki and
wins his titles back i mean
yeah i mean look um he did seem a little
bit slow in the fight you were getting
caught a little bit too much well i'm
sure he can he can fix that and he can
come back stronger okay um you stayed up
late for us we appreciate it uh get some
sleep and hopefully we'll speak to you
soon thanks a lot
thank you very much thank you take care
thank you let's return to the crisis
here at home should we the government
now saying that it is considering
bringing in the army to help deliver
fuel across the country after a weekend
of panic buying at the pumps early i
spoke to the chairman of the petrol
retailers association brian madison who
told me that stations in big cities are
the worst hit and he was
in no uncertain terms about who was to
blame
some of our members large groups with a
portfolio of sites
report 50 percent are dry as of
yesterday some even report as many as 90
percent dry whose fault is it
the whistleblower who leaked a
confidential bp report
to the cabinet uh meeting on the 16th of
september which was picked up by a main
broadcaster and
broadcast last wednesday
and immediately that happened
there was panic buying from thursday
friday saturday and yes some of the
volumes i mean one of our members uh
who's got a very large site he reported
500
more volume sales last saturday than the
previous
should we uh paul is a texas petrol
station owner joins us now hello to paul
thanks for joining us what's it like
where you are this morning good morning
well we're empty this morning so
we've kept a bit of fuel for key workers
um and that's all we've got but it was
just it was manic at the weekend it was
panic buying um
i don't really think there's any need
for panic buying at all but we're in a
bad bad place at the moment
when are you going to get more fuel do
you know paul
so i think we've been programmed in for
friday now so we'll have a week now with
no fuel
but you know
was
four 450 increase at the weekend and we
were refusing people all day yesterday
um but i think
you know if this was
on the cards and it was it was going to
happen where was the support before that
um do you think that calling in the army
is a good idea
well i think the government needs to
step up measures now because there's a
lot of people without fuel that need
fuel and how do they get fueled and how
do they get to work how do they get the
kids to school and so forth so i think
he needs to do right by the country and
and step up the measures
um who's to blame do you think for this
um
these queues i was going to call it
panic buying but i'm leading the witness
by saying that who do who do you think
is to blame
well i thought this has been going on
for weeks i think you know what started
from last week it's just exploded
um and everyone's just got they're
concerned everyone wanted fuel over the
weekend
and are you critical of motorists for
thinking i've got to get some fuel in my
car otherwise i won't be able to get the
kids to school and i won't be able to
get to work on monday or are you um
crossed about the fact that we've not
had enough lorry drivers since um june
apparently is when grant shaps the
transport secretary knew about it and
little has been done what do you think
well this has been going on for a long
time it's not just for fuel so i know
with our convenience store as well that
we've been shorted and so many products
throughout this year compared to what we
were when we threw the pandemic last
year um and there is a shortage of lorry
drivers um and you know there's new
rules there's new regulations apparently
that we've been sold um and there's
nothing being really done about it so
whether there's more drivers now coming
back from the eu or the army on the road
i think you need to put a fix in
so i was chatting to um the guy who's in
charge of the petrol retailers
association um
looking after people like you paul and
he was saying he's got his fingers
crossed that the situation will be more
or less back to normal by the end of the
week do you agree
well i hope so i mean look brian does a
fantastic job there at the pras
and you know if that's what brian's
saying i'm pretty comfortable with what
brian's saying and i hope it does
but this is monday morning
you know the site's empty
so
i don't know what we do this week
and what do people do they've only got
you know a few miles left in their tank
i'm guessing they have no alternative
but to queue up do they
yeah but i think you know you've gotten
sensible about it as well so you know
we we weren't allowing jerrycans to be
filled up you've seen some incidents on
the news where people have been trying
to fill up in plastic bags they've been
fighting on the prompts there's no need
for none of that just put in what you
need and there's no need to panic by
okay um good luck i hope that you get
your fuel on friday and things get back
to normal very quickly paul thanks a lot
appreciate it thank you
thanks
um you saw the live pictures there from
um west london as well didn't you where
people are once again queueing
apparently something like 500 increase
in the demand for fuel at the forecourt
over the weekend this is what it's
looking like at one fuel station bp with
the color of it i'm thinking isn't it i
think that is bp um at um the moment
just uh queuing sometimes to hours
people queueing either at seven o'clock
in the morning ten o'clock at night to
try and get fuel and we're being told
that there isn't a shortage of fuel well
that clearly is but the problem is
getting it from the refineries to the
pump um don't panic is what we're being
told although the prime minister and
some government ministers meeting we
believe later on today to decide whether
the only option at this stage is to
bring in our army drivers to move fuel
around the country to where it's needed
most
meantime the russian president vladimir
putin has gone on a fishing and hiking
holiday in siberia mr putin was joined
by the defense minister his regular
holiday companion for the short break
earlier this month the russian leader is
known for his love of the great outdoors
and has often been pictured bear chested
in an apparent bid to cultivate his
macho image it's quite a little fish
though isn't it um we'll be uh talking
uh about that uh in more detail later on
in the programme before all of that
though we want to take you back down to
labour party conference and joining us
from there is the mayor of london calm
in just a moment
[Music]
hello again you are watching the
breakfast show here on sky news at big
issues this morning if you're trying to
get
fuel long queues already developing
we've got images for you
at a petrol station bp station in west
london where people um have been
queueing since the early hours of this
morning chatting to a petrol station
owner in coventry he's run out of fuel
not getting any until friday the
government will be a meeting or
certainly some members of the government
meeting later on today to decide whether
now is the time to
enroll army drivers to move fuel from
the refineries to the forecourt joining
us now from brighton where labour party
conference is underway is the mayor of
london sadiq khan hello to you mr khan
thank you for joining us we look at
pictures like that
at petrol stations in your city this
morning what are your thoughts
we're hearing stories across london of
uh petrol stations running out of petrol
our emergency services and our buses
have enough and they've got some in
reserve but we're hearing stories about
care workers people who are in hospitals
who need their car to get hospital
black cab drivers private hire vehicle
drivers not being able to fuel up
and provide the services
that our city needs but also to enable
people to
get to work so we're working with the
dft to do what we can to make sure we
have fuel being provided particularly
for those key workers across our city
um who's to blame
a number of reasons uh have led to this
shambolic situation we knew in 2016 by
the way there'd be a shortage of haulage
drivers when brexit happened we knew
during the pandemic there was a problem
training up uh new haulage drivers
because obviously proximity meant you
couldn't keep uh
the training taking place without
breaching social distances we knew for
some time
this was going to happen and today
you're announcing uh that the
government's talking about bringing the
army in and it'll take some days for
them to mobilize the government yet
again
have taken their eye off the ball and
it's ordering people who are suffering
yeah although we did see you know
challenges with labour previously didn't
we um looking back this morning i didn't
realize it was as far back as 1990 but
tony blair had a similar issue to deal
with obviously it was a different reason
why there wasn't fuel at the pumps but
it took a week or so for labels to fix
it
it was 2 000 and we did fix it and one
of the things we did in 2000 the
government
is made sure some petrol stations were
reserved for those key workers the
government made sure
that there was a plan in place to
provide fuel but also
the difference was this was telegraphed
back in 2016 during the referendum
campaign but also in advance
of us leaving the european union some of
us warned the government that look
there's going to be a labor shortage as
well as a skills shortage one of the
things i've been calling for since last
january when the transition period
ending ended was
a visa for those workers we need but
also i've been saying for some time
since the pandemic uh began that we need
a coveted recovery visa because not just
in haulage in hospitality in culture in
construction those that pick our fruits
there's a desperate shortage of labour
and unless the government realizes that
many of our industries need this new
labor we're going to carry on seeing
these sorts of problems in other sectors
do you think that um boris johnson is
scum like angela rainer does
that those are not the words uh that i
would use uh but i understand angela's
anger and the passion she comes from
she's seen on a regular basis
those in her residential homes those in
her care homes those in her community
who for example have lost universal
credit being let down during the
pandemic and uh she's passionate about
that and her criticism of the prime
minister and his cabinet is their
failure to address the needs of those
who are the most vulnerable in our
society but angela speaks in the way
angela speaks not language that i would
use yeah it's inappropriate there isn't
it mr mayor
uh it's not sort of a language
that i use um but look i mean people
speak in different ways uh the key thing
is to distinguish
the prime minister who's responsible for
a lot of the policies causing real
problems across the country
and those people across the country
we've got to persuade to lend us their
vote who may have voted conservative in
the past i'm quite clear this week is
our opportunity to engage with the
country to explain to them not only are
we an effective opposition or a
government in waiting
um you're going to use your speech today
at a party conference in brighton
to try to
unite all factions of the party i mean
isn't that something that the party's
been trying to do for the best part of a
decade
well i spent yesterday at conference and
as you can know from my horse voice i
was up quite late last night and early
this morning we're in good spirits the
key thing is to remind ourselves that
we've got to be united we've got to
stick together to win the next general
election kiara's got his real changes
through yesterday really important
rachel reeves is also speaking uh today
setting out our reform of business rates
the system that's broken i'll be setting
out today our plans to address both the
twin emergencies of climate emergency
and the air pollution we're going to be
announcing a retrofit revolution to
insulate our homes to address the issue
of fuel poverty but also creating jobs
in the process and address the issue of
climate change and energy and efficiency
you're talking about uniting i mean andy
burnham he's been speaking on the fringe
of party conference he says that he
feels that uh sakia has been sidelining
uh northern metro mayors from the party
conference what would you say to him
well i was with andy burnham uh steve
rotherham last night
united
with my friends from uh the north uh
look i i've not seen the comments you're
you're talking about but i know andy
somebody who supports the leader andy's
somebody who's got a huge run of
experience in government uh as a member
of parliament and now as a brilliant
mayor in manchester and one of the
things that care is doing and the top
team is talking to the likes of mark
drakeford running wells but also mayors
across the country from tracy brabin
steve rotherham andy burnham dan jarvis
many other mayors across the country
marvin reece
and indeed myself to listen to our
points of view because we are a good
example of labour in power delivering
real change
okay let me just ask you slightly off
topic but we had amir khan on the
programme a few moments ago he says he
was thrown off a plane in american
airlines playing a week after 9 11
basically because they were two brown
boys at the front of the plane
a week after 9 11. perception is reality
that was his view um it's a challenge
isn't it
yeah i have problems uh going to america
being stopped at the airport longer than
colleagues either with who aren't brown
or muslim it's been a big issue for some
time this issue of racial profiling not
just by the way in america in other
places across the globe i think it's
really good for amir to talk about his
experiences one of the good things
since the election of the new president
in america president biden is some of
the toxicity
from president trump's time has now
hopefully gone one of the things we've
got to do is to make sure we speak out
when we feel we've been treated uh
wrongly and one of the things i'm
pleased that i may have done is speak
about about his experiences because not
everyone is a former world champion not
everyone is olympic medalist but
everyone has a platform and by people
like amer talking about it hopefully it
makes those in authority in america
realize that it's not really on and what
it does by the way is it makes people
like emir and others who love america
have a sort of weird taste in their
mouth and a sort of unhappiness with
that great country that's why it's
really important
for people not to be judged by the color
of their skin or the god they worship
okay it's good to talk to you good luck
with your speech today thank you
thanks kate stay safe thanks you too
more on the fuel crisis coming up in
just a second